let's just bring you some breaking news
we're just getting this in from the uh
secretary of state for business and
energy quasi quitting uh he has put this
out on social media saying the uk will
phase out the import of russian oil and
oil products by the end of 2022
this transition will give the market
businesses and supply chains more than
enough time to replace russian imports
which make up eight percent of uk demand
he goes on to say businesses should use
this year to ensure a smooth transition
so that consumers will not be affected
the government will also work with
companies through a new task force on
oil to support them to make use of this
period in finding alternative supplies
the uk is a significant producer of oil
and oil products plus we hold
significant reserves beyond russia the
vast majority of our imports come from
reliable partners such as the united
states netherlands and the gulf will
work with them this year to secure
further supplies
the market has already begun to
ostracize russian oil with nearly 70 per
cent of it currently unable to find a
buyer
finally while the uk is not dependent on
russian natural gas four percent of our
supply i am exploring options to end
this
all together that's coming from the uk
secretary for uh business and energy and
that's the uk government's position on
russian oil and oil products promising
to phase out the import import of oil
and oil products from russia by the end
of 2022